et alors le tondeur comment ça marche
eh ben il n'y a plus de place il ya plus
de place du tout on s'est fini c'est
même plus la peine de téléphoner
y a plus place jusqu'à demain après ya
encore des places mais ça marche très
très fort et je suis très content on va
jouer ça en principe jusqu'au mois de
juillet oui et je veux dire c'est une
expérience formidable parce que c'est la
première fois je fais du théâtre et bon
j'avais un petit peu peur c'est normal
parce que après avoir été tout seul sur
scène pendant une dizaine d'années là je
joue avec d'autres on partage la
trouille à neuf et on partage avec le
public d'une manière très différente moi
je prends un pied formidables à jouer
cette pièce et je souhaite vraiment que
les gens viennent encore de plus en plus
nombreux parce que vraiment ça marche
très bien je suis tellement content
c'est une pièce de robert lamoureux
qu'il avait créé en cinquante huit sous
un autre titre il avait créé cette pièce
que ça plaît le la brune que voilà et on
a trouvé que le taxer le tigre était un
petit peu il veut passer de mode
on l'a réactualisé en tombeur de l'ombre
dans la vie tu es un tombeur uche mais
plus maintenant a puisque voilà un petit
moment et là et il va falloir gentil et
non non je me suis beaucoup pas s'agit
de puits bon j'aime bien le roi vous
pensez que l'aide soit un ton bien
imaginer qu'ils soient pas mariés vous
plairait comme garçons c'est exactement
la question que j'étais en train de me
poser ma foi je trouve
regardez attentivement et je trouvais
qu'il pouvait tout à fait être un
tombeur
il est très bien elle a beaucoup de
chance mais après on a beaucoup de
chance a dit que quand j'étais enfant
mes parents me disaient si tu es pas mon
père me disent tu veux tomber les petits
pour les faire rire mais voilà il c'est
vrai que c'est un des atouts majeurs
il est beau il fait rire les filles
tentant faits réels et je suis sûr que
ça marche
1 les filles voyez on va passer aux jeux
wii